[Music]
I was blown away
Kerry Washington opening up about the
end of scandal and teases a crazy season
finale on Wednesdays Good Morning
America how do you and the rest of the
cast feel about it I know I think we're
all a little sad but also we feel
grateful to have the information it's
nice actually to go into the last season
knowing that it's our last season
because we're already talking about how
it's gonna be like no-holds-barred
better than ever
no holding punches putting it all out on
the table
mama Pope's back mama Pope is back
housewife or Olivia nah I mean I never
in my wildest dreams could have imagined
that we are ending the season with
Olivia Pope
who she is and I've done some crazy
stuff but where we end this season makes
me so excited about WoW is it because
I've never it's beyond what I could have
imagined and Vladi ators are in for a
treat check out this first look at
Thursday's two-hour season finale this
is my mother she hired someone to kill
Mellie we need to figure out who that
assassin is and shut them down they're
out there somewhere because this entire
thing is completely off the books you
need to hire us you up for the job
of course we are Carrie told et we
probably won't see Olivia Pope tackling
motherhood on the show it's handled but
looking back the actress says she's
grateful for where she's at in her
career now I have a beautiful husband
and beautiful kids and I'm really happy
about my life and I love my job and I
get to bring all of that to work for one
more season I feel really blessed we see
that
[Music]
you